un manuel entier de paragraphes de
dissertation oui c'est le concept que
j'ai créée il y a quelques années et ça
a bien marché
du coup j'en ai écrit des paragraphes de
dissertation jusqu'à plusieurs centaines
certaines années je n'ai pas compté mais
au total je ne dois pas être loin des
1000 paragraphe
donc j'ai un peu d'expérience en ce qui
concerne la d'action d'un paragraphe de
dissertation
[Musique]
si vous voulez savoir comment rédiger un
paragraphe de dissertation parfait vous
regardez la bonne vidéo
mais avant de vous révéler ma méthode je
veux vous rappeler qu'il y a une chose
qui est encore plus importante que de
savoir rédiger un paragraphe c'est la
méthodologie et oui faut lire vos
paragraphe ne servira à rien si vous ne
savez pas faire une dissertation donc
inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuits de
méthodologie de la dissertation soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit en utilisant celui qui est dans la
description de cette vidéo
les élèves l'adorent donc je sais que
vous ne serez pas déçus c'est un cours
par email donc vous pouvez regarder
cette vidéo jusqu'au bout et puis vous
découvrirez ma méthodologie après ou
bien dans les prochains jours je vous
dis ça parce que cette vidéo est
importante elle est importante parce
qu'elle va vous faire économiser
beaucoup de temps en fait pour la
plupart des élèves c'est long de rédiger
le développement de la dissertation ils
ne savent pas comment s'y prendre don
qu'ils hésitent et ils perdent du temps
mais pour vous ça c'est fini parce qu'à
la fin de cette vidéo vous saurez
exactement les étapes à suivre et les
techniques à appliquer pour rédiger un
paragraphe parfait en dissertation
allez je vous explique la première étape
la première étape de la rédaction d'un
paragraphe de dissertation c'est la
réaction de l'argument un argument c'est
une affirmation particulière présenté à
l'appui d'une démonstration et dans le
développement de votre dissertation
l'argument c'est l'idée directrice d'un
paragraphe c'est pour ça que c'est
l'étape la plus importante de la
rédaction du paragraphe est en plus de
présenter l'idée directrice du
paragraphe la première phrase est celle
qui attire l'attention du correcteur
parce qu'il lit le développement de la
dissertation en diagonale cette phrase
est donc crucial alors je vais vous dire
rapidement comment la rédiger parce que
j'ai déjà publié une vidéo dans laquelle
je vous donne des consignes précises
pour le faire vous trouverez facilement
cette vidéo sur ma chaîne elle commence
par arguments de dissertation en résumé
il y a 6 chose importante pour rédiger
l'argument la première phrase j'ai par
ailleurs
premièrement cette phrase doit être
courte avec un seul verbe conjugué
ensuite elle doit être très clair il
faut que le correcteur puisse la
comprendre instantanément
troisième chose vous devez affirmé
l'idée de l'argument avec nuance c'est
seulement une hypothèse qui apporte un
élément de réponse à la problématique de
la dissertation quatrième chose
la phrase ne comporte aucun type de
connaissances
ça viendra plus tard dans le paragraphe
en revanche elle doit renvoyer à la
formulation du sujet pour renforcer
l'impression de pertinence de l'argument
et ça c'est la 5ème choses et enfin 6e
chose
la phrase contient un mode liaison qui
connecte l'idée directrice du paragraphe
à celle du paragraphe précédent
j'en ai terminé avec les six
caractéristiques que doivent avoir les
premières phrases de vaud paragraphe de
dissertation je vous montre un exemple
la maîtrise des désirs reposerait sur la
sélection des influences cette phrase
fedimmo donc elle est courte elle est
aussi clair ne comporte aucun mot
technique et sa construction est basique
grâce au conditionnel reposerait je
présente bien l'idée comme une hypothèse
la phrase ne comporte aucune
connaissance c'est un paragraphe que
j'avais près rédigées pour des sujets
sur le thème du désir
donc l'argument contient le mot d
dir et enfin il n'y a pas de mots de
liaison parce que je ne sais pas où je
vais utiliser ce paragraphe ci c'est le
premier d'une grande partie je pourrais
écrire simplement tout d'abord la
maîtrise de désir reposerait sur la
sélection des influences
si l'idée directrice s'oppose à celle du
parieur précédent jerry crierait par
exemple la maîtrise de désir reposerait
cependant sur la sélection des
influences ça dépend de la nature
logique de la connexion entre les deux
paragraphes
encore une fois si vous voulez des
consignes précises pour rédiger la
première phrase d'un paragraphe du
développement aller voir ma vidéo dont
le titre commence par arguments de
dissertation allez on passe à l'étape
suivante la deuxième étape de la
rédaction d'un paragraphe de
dissertation c'est le développement de
l'argument vous expliquer l'idée
directrice du paragraphe en quelques
phrases au moins deux sinon c'est trop
court votre objectif c'est simplement
d'apporter des précisions pour
convaincre le correcteur de la
pertinence de votre argument du coup
aucune connaissance nécessaire à ce
stade
regardez comment j'ai développé
l'argument non paragraphe d'exemple
cette hypothèse s'inscrit dans la
perspective mimétique selon laquelle les
tendances nes et s'intensifie dans
l'individu lorsqu'il les décèle chez ses
semblables
il suffirait dès lors pour étouffer les
aspirations envahissante de se couper
totalement de leurs sources afin de
prévenir le trouble de l'âme comme on
reste hors d'atteinte d'une maladie
contagieuse
en pratique il s'agirait de trier les
occasions de la vie sociale en fonction
des influences émotionnel que l'on n'en
redoute
j'explique en trois phrases ce que je
veux dire dans l'argument par sélection
des influences les hommes se contaminent
émotionnellement les uns les autres
donc les désirs c'est un peu comme avec
une maladie contagieuse
il faut faire attention à ne pas
fréquenter des personnes qui peuvent
nous inspirer de mauvais désir la
rédaction est moins soignée que celle de
la première phrase parce que la deuxième
partie du paragraphe est bien moins
importante que la première phrase peau
nettement on ne sait même pas si le
correcteur va lire ses phrases donc vous
pouvez les écrire plus rapidement allez
on passe à l'étape suivante
la troisième étape de la réflexion d'un
paragraphe de dissertation c'est
l'introduction d'une connaissance
vous avez présenté l'idée directrice du
paragraphe et vous l'avez expliqué en
quelques phrases il est maintenant temps
de faire appel à une autorité extérieure
pour renforcer la crédibilité de votre
argument en pratique vous introduisez la
connaissance en une seule phrase
cette phrase est moins importante que la
toute première du paragraphe mais elle
est quand même important parce que la
mobilisation du savoir est un enjeu de
la dissertation et aussi parce que le
correcteur va y jeter un coup d'oeil
pour être efficace cette phrase doit
avoir trois caractéristiques
tout d'abord elle indique clairement la
connaissance que vous mobiliser en
particulier si vous citez un ouvrage il
faut souligner le titre deuxième
caractéristique cette phrase doit relier
la connaissance à l'idée directrice du
paragraphe le correcteur doit comprendre
facilement que la connaissance mobilisés
et pertinente troisième caractéristiques
comme la première phrase du paragraphe
celle ci doit être plutôt courte c'est
plus efficace donc plus facile à
comprendre
voyons comment j'ai mobilisé une
connaissance dans mon paragraphe
d'exemple
c'est ainsi une véritable quarantaine
que sénèque préconise à son amie lucie
du ce alors je dit en substance que le
philosophe sénèque a recommandé à son
ami lui sinus de se protéger des
mauvaises influences la phrase indique
clairement la référence avec l'énoncé
nec et lucie plus elle la relie à l'idée
directrice du paragraphe la sélection
des influences avec le mot quarantaine
et enfin elle fait 12 moudon plein est
plutôt courte
vous pouvez aussi inséré un mot de
liaison pour connecter l'introduction de
la connaissance avec le développement de
l'argument comme je lé fais avec le
connecteur logique d'illustration ainsi
mais vous n'êtes pas obligés parce que
c'est souvent compliqué c'est tout pour
cette étape on passe à la suivante
la quatrième étape de la rédaction d'un
par la garde de dissertation c'est le
développement de la connaissance
votre objectif c'est d'apporter des
précisions à propos de la connaissance
que vous venez d'introduire afin de
prouver aux correcteurs que vous la
maîtriser et que vous ne faites pas du
name dropping cette partie est la moins
importante du paragraphe
car c'est là que vous dévalez vos
connaissances là vous devez foncé sans
vous prendre la tête
ce n'est pas grave si la rédaction et
moins soigné parce que c'est la partie
que le correcteur lira le moins
attentivement voyons comment je me suis
pris dans paragraphe d'exemple je ne
vais pas lire cette partie mettez la
vidéo en pause si vous voulez la lire
pour développer la référence je détaille
ce que dit le philosophe sénèque dans sa
lettre à son ami lui sidious je cite une
phrase de la lettre et je souligne le
titre du livre
la citation c'est un petit plus ce n'est
pas obligatoire allez il reste dernière
étape la cinquième étape de la rédaction
d'un paragraphe de dissertation c'est le
rappel de l'idée directrice entre
objectifs c'est simplement de fermer le
propos en aidant le lecteur à mémoriser
l'idée importante du paragraphe en
pratique
contentez-vous simplement de reformuler
la première phrase du paragraphe
l'idéal c'est de lier cette phrase de
conclusion au passage qui la précède
pour soigner la fluidité du paragraphe
mais bon idéal c'est l'idéal regardons
la dernière phrase de mon paragraphe
d'exemple il faudrait donc se soustraire
aux mauvaises influences pour rester
maître de ses désirs la première phrase
du paragraphe c'était la maîtrise des
désirs reposerait sur la sélection des
influences donc je dis quasiment la même
chose je parle de soustraction plutôt
que de sélection mais l'idée est la même
c'est l'idée directrice du paragraphe je
lis cette phrase de conclusion à la
partie précédente du paragraphe grâce au
connecteur logique de conséquence donc
vous connaissez maintenant les cinq
étapes pour rédiger un paragraphe de
dissertation en résumé vous devez
présenter l'idée directrice du
paragraphe en une phrase développé cette
idée en quelques phrases introduire une
connaissance pertinente par rapport à
l'idée directrice développer cette
connaissance est enfin rappelé l'idée
directrice du paragraphe
tiens à propos de rappel je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez vous inscrire à
mon cours gratuits de méthodologie de la
dissertation soit en cliquant sur le
lien qui apparaît maintenant en haut à
droite de la vidéo soit en cliquant sur
celui qui est dans la description de
cette vidéo
voilà voilà j'espère que cette vidéo
vous sera utile je suis romain je suis
toujours avec mon fidèle aristote et
vous étiez sur mille idées de culture
générale rappelez vous vous n'avez pas
besoin de vous prendre la tête pour
rédiger un super paragraphe de
dissertation
[Musique]